yeah I know it's uh it's um
not the Skyrim theme
uh How does it go again
I I always accidentally do like the Game
of Thrones too in my head
that's Skyrim um
how can I remember it I mean I
don't know
yeah dude number one fan right over
there yeah
[Music]
I can do a better version if I remember
the that's just like that that's just
the hug
where's my phone it goes It goes like I
can't believe
I honestly I'm also blanking like really
hard after hearing it so much
because there's also like the easy theme
the uh
[Music]
you do three sheets
[Music]
it's like I'm going to the end of the
episode it's the simple chord
progression maybe you remember the
lyrics to the theme song it would help
it's not that yeah
that's the um yeah here we go here we go
standby how many creators of son of a
dungeon does it take to figure out the
theme song
their own show
oh
dude what is this
no because this is the the theme
oh he's locking in
he's beginning to believe
[Music]
[Music]
then he does a keychains this is what
I'm thinking about this part here
so it's
oh then he does this
turn back now it's gonna go back then
now
[Music]
oh there we go
[Music]
um
being
good
I'm missing the second one
[Music]
that's it
oh yeah
[Music]
wow and then Jordan does his solo yeah I
prefer acapella yeah we'll do that later
that'll be on the soundtrack yeah
let's check that on Spotify
[Music]
honestly the best lyrics ever written in
my opinion
everywhere
you forget about nurner though
[Music]
because lyrically I didn't see that
coming at all yeah
Court change
[Music]
that's Warren coming in
it's good
that's Nico
the Little Freestyle definitely did yeah
yeah that's pretty good that's beautiful
it took a moment sorry no thank you we
got there I feel like I'm glad we can
slightly accomplish that this guitar is
actually in tune too so yeah anyways uh
sweet what up we did it uh son of a
dungeon guys episode 100 million we
called we did it nine nine hours of
content later wow that was a big show
yeah man what did you do on this show
yeah I watched it yeah
to keep my eyes open the whole time yeah
yeah so and you are yeah I'm new here
what's up
that was a lot that was a lot of stuff
and the reason it was a lot of stuff is
because we always we went into this
whole thing going hey let's make a show
that we've done before like we've done d
d stuff before it's easy to film we get
a huge story out of it that's cool
however then the whole approach we took
was now we are going to treat all that
stuff we filmed as if it's feature film
content and do visual effects and sound
design all the stuff of the editing and
so it's like the post like
the post would have taken just as long
you know if that was like an actual nine
episode series yeah like if it wasn't
guys at a table and we're just in
costumes and stuff that would have taken
like almost the same amount of time
rings of power yeah yeah yeah so if we
didn't do VFX so that means Jordan
wouldn't be here
um it's true yeah
we would probably have this done in a
fraction of the time
thanks
yeah because how much of the did you
have built before the season and unreal
Sam like zero I mean well I mean what's
that I don't know I mean that's that's
such a hard window to like yeah talk
about because like we
like uh January 5th of this year like
Carmichael was at my house yeah and we
were hanging out and I was like dude
here's there's all the diagrams for all
the tables yeah or like the rough
layouts it got rougher the further into
the later Maps we got yeah but you know
like that was that that was the first
level there was like
that level of planning so yeah we were
drinking some good meat that night yeah
I mean it'll do that to you he has been
made fans male yeah Mead fan yeah it's
too sweet well it's too historical to
like yeah pass up yeah you're like oh
damn
eons of civilization all wrapped up into
one little bottle it's like come on yeah
I did Mead for the for the first episode
release but I watched with a few friends
we got Mead
it was so it's so sweet it's hard to
hard to stomach honestly there's a lot
yeah of course there's there's a lot of
types if you get that Danish one that
comes in a stone bottle
that stuff is the syrup sugar stuff I
had a Whimsical one called Chancellor's
meat and there's a
notebooks is that the sparkling one or
no it's not sparkling okay
about drinking Mead but it's for real
it's not real yeah
you know when you brew alcohol the idea
is that the yeast eats the sugar so by
the time you're drinking it most of it's
gone so if it's sweet that means they
basically ferment it and then they add
stuff in yeah after it's done fermenting
and the yeast is dead you know we did
did like the couple Drunk History shots
in the show but we should do Drunk
History at the drunk off Mead yeah it's
actual Drunk History I like that that'd
be good one full season of drunk d d
usually that's good off camera yeah and
uh Fenner and I will also be drunk while
doing the visual effects and it'll just
be a big mess yeah someone will be drunk
when they upload it but you have to be
driven to watch it Vimeo instead yeah
like oh crap we forgot to put a title on
this yeah
oh man yeah it's uh it's funny because
it doesn't really feel like it's
done it to me I mean does it feel like
it's done to you guys finally yes if you
feel because it's uploaded it's it's
uploaded
enjoying the comments uh
it's like season one episode eight
everyone's like yeah we did it we did it
I'm like okay I gotta do this thing I
gotta still do this I gotta do this okay
I'm still working so it doesn't sink in
but now after season two I the weight of
that time and energy now just sinks in
it's a lot do you think that there were
more man hours on this season than last
yes because there were more
people putting in hours oh you're right
yeah the team did grow quite a bit yeah
which was extremely helpful yeah yeah
people dig this this is great very
positive comments everyone's loving it
that's cool man yeah
um
the only negative comments are just
about D now
just exciting correct on the other
ethically accurate about anything being
rendered
about anything they do
that feels unfair yeah they instantly
instantly appear in water with no time
to breathe in air and now they get to
hold their breath for three minutes come
on yeah can't wait for season three oh
boy well yeah uh disappointment will
they be I don't know I don't know I mean
the thing is is that it's it's nice like
okay well just rewinding a little bit
you know yeah it's it's
I've I've said this a few times but like
ultimately it's you know
you know what you're like writing an
idea for a video or some concept or a
script and you're like you have an idea
and then you go to write it yourself
you're like all right what's what do I
do and it's really easy to get like you
you you can like lock up you're like oh
what do I do this sucks this is terrible
you know like or maybe the idea was more
funny when you were brainstorming it
with someone or something like that it's
like
that's why I think this season was so
good was because it's like it's I think
the truest form of like that
brainstorming session that everyone's
having fun and getting hyped about and
then it turns into the actual story you
know it's like yeah it's not that it
it's it's like that collaborative
storytelling element where it's like
yeah sure we have story ideas and
there's like a path and a guide here but
it's like if I was just gonna bang out a
script of like that storyline it would
like totally suck you know and it's just
that idea of all right everyone's
writing the script right here and it
turned out really well and I think
that's just super cool because yeah like
I don't know it's like that's why I like
watching the show anyways I'm like these
hilarious moments that these guys come
up with yeah and like make that's what
like truly makes it interesting yeah
anyways the season uh season three would
be like one all the ducks have to get
lined up everyone's got to be down for
it
and we also have to be
super interested in the next step of the
story
that's that's where my stance is if we
have a cooler idea well the cooler idea
is going to happen first I mean I have
yeah like I I like don't want to do
season three at this second yeah because
I've been working with Carmichael about
all these like high concept other like d
d things we could be doing yeah I'm like
yeah that'd be cool but
but you know give a breath for season
three when you have like a big big story
or whatever going like this it's like so
cool to like keep pushing it further and
further yeah
um yeah do your backpacking trip around
Europe yeah come back another semester
yeah yeah
so yeah do you do you feel like more
fulfillment out of telling these longer
stories than like a more varied short
form oh yeah totally totally this is
this is way more yeah I mean because
it's not even like well once again it's
like it's it's totally scratches that
itch of like oh sweet I made a movie or
I wrote something huge or whatever but
like
um it's like the work the storytelling
is distributed you know across everyone
like I mean even Carmichael like it
doesn't you know you don't make an
appearance during the show but like
you're you know pulling the strings you
know as you're watching it as well and
it's yeah it's super cool
if it like
when when a corridor short film gets
made it's like there's the that whole
process of like Sam brought up writing
the script alone and then and we're kind
of seeing that with some of the other
projects coming down the pipeline for
the website like there's the whole
writing process
where you constantly have to revise
revise revise revise and then once
everyone is satisfied with it then you
go shoot it
whereas like you do half of that work
and then you go to a table with a bunch
of friends and everyone sees where that
goes with the understanding that like
it's got to build to something and
everyone around the table is like in
some fashion a Storyteller so they
they're pushing the scenes forward yeah
I mean like yeah it's way more fun like
the payoff of like having D have a
conversation with his like orphan
younger brother like sidekick who then
also is being given away to his
billionaire father coming to terms with
who would be the better dad like like
getting a moment like that or like
seeing them like argue over like who
killed Ren or whatever you know it's
like it's just like so deep and like so
so rich that like you can't just like
hop into that if you're making a three
or four minute long video or something
that's not entirely planned at all was
well there's a little planning is you
give Dee a nightmare about being under
the ocean at that point you and I are
ready for the ocean sequence
and
we've oh you've already given Jake a
potion of water breathing and you gave
Dee a potion of love
and they by themselves have a moment and
make that exchange to give each other
the different items which then allows
Jake to go after d and save his life by
making a mind flare fall in love with
him and he has a potion of water
breathing under the ocean trapped yeah
yeah that whole thing is kind of funny
like actually there is something worth
talking about there which is like the
idea okay so like
you have a script you know you're
shooting it or there's Direction versus
this which is technically it's improv
like there's bumpers you know so to
speak but like ultimately it is like
improv storytelling so you can't fully
predict what people do
but that being said like numbers is a
good good yeah it's like bumpers like
like look like you're gonna hit at least
one pin like yeah
exactly exactly but like that was the
thing with like the last one which is
like all right we're doing a finale here
let's do like a big setup so it's like I
basically tell D like the session before
like you're having a nightmare about
drowning underwater or whatever and the
whole time I'm like I'm really working
hard to make sure they end up there and
it just so happens that like yeah they
they perfectly managed to like find some
crap and give it to the right people
that like it's just like
like I was trying to work them into a
corner too of like okay look you guys
are fighting this thing and everyone
disappears and one of your friends
disappears you're [ __ ] you know like
you have like one way to get there but
you have no idea where they went and so
then suddenly they magically managed to
and then figured that out and make it
work and it was like totally on their
own which is awesome there's such
another level of Randomness too because
if D had succeeded on his save to not
get plane shifted yeah then what would
have happened then you know I mean I
mean like that was the goal in that
whole boss battle which is like I'm just
trying to pick take someone out of the
fight to make it so they're at a
disadvantage but you know whatever well
Bob I think was on the the uh the target
uh line for pulling out of that fight
too I think D and with Bob were the
targets yeah
it's crazy though but it's it's funny
things could have been so different if
any one person succeeds or fails any
role yeah you know that makes it so hard
to imagine if
all the roles deter to stop the worm
failed
where was the plot there that was gonna
happen like it's such a Multiverse tree
of things that could have happened
especially with the fact that Bob like
ran away yeah
when they probably polymorph the worm
it's just the three of them there yeah
but I guess they did have the HUD up
yeah yeah so I think that like it's only
in their favor so that that's they're
always in a higher chance of success
because Jake can do tiny Hut instantly
with the jacked up rules because
normally it takes 10 minutes and a round
of combat six seconds so it's like
that's a
basically would have been possible but
yeah
feel fun although what happens to the
tiny Hut if the worm like ate the ground
around it and everything the tiny Hut
would probably be swallowed
that's my swallow a tiny Hood that's my
opinion
yeah but it's kind of funny like but
like that whole that whole like end
finale thing too it's like
we were talking about this the other day
with when when Ren dies everyone's like
oh my God yeah because a lot of the
comments said in the show are like oh
you guys make it too easy and they're
always like winning and they're
overpowered and it's like it's kind of
true but like like the way I'm trying I
like I do want them to die because it's
interesting when players like die
because it's like oh [ __ ] this is a huge
deal but like I just never want to be
the one to kill him because it feels
cheap because it's like my world like
you walk into room and a thousand spikes
writing down on you and you're dead haha
yeah yeah I win you know uh but like
that whole thing with the end is like
I'm just trying to bring him to the
brink of death and then I let go I like
I'm like I want you to have one hit
point and then I just want to see how
you [ __ ] the last hit point of yourself
yeah because then it's so much more
interesting like with d it's like the
whole goal is like all right I'm gonna
put you underwater and I'm gonna bring
you to one hit point and then he's like
freeze octopus and I'm like [ __ ] you
it's like come on like I was like I was
trying to like have him drown slash beat
but fight this thing yeah basically and
then once he's down to like 10 hit
points I'll be like now the other guys
show up you know but then it was just
like ah [ __ ] he's freezing the octopus
and I'm like okay now there's the other
brain he's there now too and so I'm
gonna have him fight but yeah it didn't
quite they they you know they handled it
really well so yeah
because but that's yeah that would have
been pretty fun though if like I could
we could have like gotten to that point
with one of them because yeah some
someone would have totally died there
anyways yeah
uh awesome next time
so
you came in
uh about halfway through the shoot
of the tabletop the table top table top
shooting and then you're like oh cool
we're gonna I'm gonna edit this for like
three months and I'll be like hey thanks
for the thanks for the work a year later
yeah
um
what how how would you say the editing
process in this is like
different from another production
uh yeah I mean it's just like every
timeline
gets so
bloated with so many different like
layers and weird effects and different
like previous shots and then the actual
shot
um and so it just gets just looking at
the Timeline gets like a lot more
complicated than just editing like a
short film or something where it's like
yeah you have your takes and then you
know that maybe you have like an
adjustment layer on some things or you
know like one one title graphic here or
there but this is like
like a hundred percent using the
timeline 100 of the time
uh you know billion audio tracks a
billion video tracks so it's it's a lot
to like wrap your head around and that's
why I like the qcing process was so
important too because there's so many
chances for just like the the widescreen
bars to just be like one frame off and
then you just see like
are we under now yeah oh yeah so many
plates spinning at every frame of the
show you know you know we exported the
the final export of episode nine
foreign
middle of the night before the morning
of upload yeah because the export that
we were ready to upload actually had
more glitches than we thought it would
really sad yeah a whole green screenshot
had to get removed
part of one yeah yeah it's like the
background was just like I don't know it
was just glitched out and it was not
there and honestly
I just decided it was done but it was
like it was like right it was like right
at the end so I was like okay I'll just
speaking of green screen shots Jordan
yeah uh
how how do you think the green screen
workflow went
for this show yeah it's interesting
because literally as soon as I arrived
at Corridor we started season one
so yeah I was a part of that VFX
pipeline which of course was way more
filled with manual matting and this was
before like
it wasn't before Runway I'm all in like
AI roto tools but it did require a vast
amount of like manual frame by frame
painting out of seams and cracks and the
torn paper you know green screen and
stuff like that and that was a nightmare
because also obviously in Adobe in After
Effects there's no procedural pipeline
that is built here it's like you can
copy paste some things but you've got
pre-compcept the Wazoo and you've kind
of just got to rebuild it and that's
what I did I like assembly lined it back
in After Effects I just basically did
all the Roto in one pass across all the
shots and et cetera et cetera for all
the shots I was assigned but with this
one it was way way easier because again
you've got the Plug and Play aspect like
Fenner belted absolute awesome like
default script that I could plug stuff
into at the top and then I just tweaked
the key I you know I tweaked The Edge uh
color uh to match the background I
tweaked the D Spot I tweak all the
little aspects that trickle down and you
can pump through shots way way faster so
so good it's like it couldn't have come
at a better time because I think if we
had the same pipeline we did for season
one with the asks of season two I think
it would have become a huge time suck
yeah there's definitely more shots yeah
yeah it felt really big
um even this even with that with the
pipeline in place it still felt like a
really big show so considering episode
nine is like the Beast of beasts you
know uh Fenner and I ended on a Sprint
for that episode and
when we were done it felt it felt like
we'd really we'd really gotten through
something pretty epic so yeah there's a
feeling of reward but again we're still
like we're not sure if that spreadshe's
gonna be updated today
we're gonna be like on edge a little bit
you know oh that's funny I mean it's
uploaded so yeah yeah so that's that's
that's one check we might see a comment
that's like oh my God yeah yeah oh
that's right and finally the audience is
key seeing her work yeah the final pass
yeah
crowdsourcing QC man yeah dude yeah and
then we sell it to Netflix after they're
after their QC pass do you if if we do a
season three would you guys continue to
do it in premiere no no so this is the
end of of yeah I would love it to be the
end of Premiere
um I did a small test in resolve
said because it's a multi-cam
production
resolve is great with multicam I might
just need somebody to walk me through it
who knows resolve better and
multi-camming
but making the
essentially
the pre-comps inside resolve so that way
within each sequence are the little bit
of layers that we need for every camera
switch
that was falling apart when I was doing
my test compared to Premiere is chuggy
sucks but it nails that process
instantly when you're out in the main
timeline you know we're still chuggy
because it's chuggy it's in Premiere
yeah but when you're outside in that
main timeline it is pretty quick to just
like switch through all the cameras like
really fast the second you go into that
it gets way scarier and it crashes like
quick all the time and the way that we
had like the picture and picture thing
set up is like you know you have all of
the raw footage that's each angle is
nested and then each of those nests is
in a bigger nest and then the picture
and picture ones are those nests
duplicated nested again oh good and then
inside that there's a bunch of mats that
everything is uh set matted through and
there's like a very specific order of
like a transform effect a set matte
effect and then an offset effect yeah so
that you can adjust
why do we need it because we don't
always go to the camera angle yeah and
so since it's like vertically aligned
which looks better but it is you know
people move a lot more so it's harder to
keep them in the thing you have to go in
and basically just have like hold
keyframes inside that picture in picture
inside the offset on the matted thing
and once you get that you're literally
in limbo like Inception level limbo and
there's times where you're speaking to
Mr Adobe yeah
the air around you starts becoming the
blue screen you're like and there's
times where like you will mess up
something you're like oh like I moved
them a little too much and you go and do
and then undo doesn't work anymore oh
and you're like oh that's that's weird
you go out into the main time on it it's
undoing stuff that you did out there but
not inside and then when that happens
you're like oh I'm about to crash and
then you have to immediately save and
exit and then it takes 15 minutes it
takes 15 minutes and then when you hit X
then it white screens I think Premiere
should probably have like a predictive
like crash warning that's what that was
I was able to predict it crash to like
the second yeah because like if you can
do it why can't they you know it's like
they should have a thing that says that
like look this is not going well we're
about to crash like we've vlogged all
the others I forgot how to undo it's not
looking good with the operation you just
did we checked their log it crashed it a
while ago so here's like a 10 second
timer if
yeah we're probably about to crash
that's one thing that nuke does very
well is like when it when it does crash
it almost takes everything down
it'll make a new project file it almost
always has a there's a more recent auto
save of the script would you like to
open it and it's from the second it
crashed and it's like that's the kind of
implementation that is very very hard
audition does that I was very lucky
because I was doing my my final pass on
episode nine and it was like okay I can
get this done in like
two and a half hours no problem
four hours later
because it kept crashing not just the
program but turning off my computer
you don't need this anymore you buy but
every time I reopened up audition it was
either right where I left off or one
action before and I was like oh my God
where is this in Premiere yeah Premiere
needed it like because and then also
it's not even good at like recovering
every time it crashes either because
sometimes you reopen it after a crash
it's like oh we'll make a recovery file
we're so sorry that was that was our bad
here's a new file save as yeah but a lot
of times it doesn't even do that uh when
we're like that deep into the nests and
you just have to be like okay I guess
it's time to make a new version we got
into the double digits yeah on episode
one episode one V10 on episode nine we
got to v9 so we almost hit double digits
so close but literally like the like the
last day it was still you know opening
it would crash it and we had a huge
problem on a few a few episodes ago
where we had to go in to uh Seth had
like a really good trick where you
basically like take the text file of the
premiere project and erase the version
number so you can open it in an earlier
version of Premiere and then re-save it
and then just receive it in that version
and then you have to like save as again
into 2022
um and then it works but until then
it'll open and then it's immediately
freeze and the second you click anything
it crashes and there's like you couldn't
even open it and then save as to like
even save it at all it got so bad that I
had my auto save set for every two
minutes and it's because of how autosave
works it it pauses what you're doing and
you sit there for five five to ten
seconds and then it's like it interrupts
your creative thinking and I'm like
why can't autosave just be invisible in
the background and every time you need
to show someone something like hey check
this out and then right as you hit play
goes honestly yep auto save I had to
think in After Effects where it would
the auto save would pop up and it would
take 15 to 20 minutes to save the
project file until I realized that if
you click on it
it will do it a hundred times faster but
you have to click on it it doesn't
there's no reason it's just one of those
things where you get so fed up you start
trying random things and then you have
like Austin just described a 100 step
hack yeah that you've discovered born
out of pure frustration yeah it's it's
wild man so it would be lovely to do any
other son of a dungeon in resolve uh we
just gotta do tests but yeah
episode one season two in resolve we
just need to do that yeah well Austin
needed uh a whole bunch of Motion
Graphics for this season that obviously
weren't in the first one you were using
something also also
one of the reasons project files it's
crazy yeah they look so cool and then
Premiere is just like nah like where the
water breathing in episode nine that was
taking the render from like two hours
maybe to like 24. uh and even like
because there's like a few small ones
but then at the end when they're about
to like drown that that moghart's on
there for like two minutes
um and that just it pauses the render it
just can't handle it and I think they
just did like an update that's gonna
make uh more efficient with mogritz but
yeah 2023. I don't only take 23 hours
yeah yeah
it's a moving like 50 by 50 pixel icon
did you try clicking on it yeah
I tried to click it on everything but so
I ended up having to export all of the
water breathing mogrits just in After
Effects because I couldn't even like
like dragging it into Premiere and then
just exporting the ones that are already
in the timeline also like you know 24
hours to render so I had to go in and
basically duplicate comps to make a
version for each instance of that
moderate and then render that out with
Alpha and then drop that into the
timeline and disable all the mogrits
because it just couldn't handle it is
because this is the first time I've
heard of like mogrits this is I'm not
even we learned about it in Indie Mogul
yeah the the principle of bogus is oh
awesome like because like you can make
it in after effect you can make whatever
you want in After Effects and then you
just drag whichever properties you want
into the essential Graphics uh tab or
whatever and then you export it and then
boom you got a really sweet template in
Premiere that you can it's like a
controller for
it's like a dynamic it's an instant
template it's like yeah it's like you
make little Graphics templates that have
variables you can tweak or add text or
you know customize it's like almost what
we wanted originally from Dynamic link
yeah that's the thing with the whole
dynamic system in Adobe it's like it's a
dream come true and it creates a hell
yeah because it works just just well
enough for you to want to keep using it
but punishes you so severely for yeah
for being interested and that's like if
you have a moderate that's like simple
enough then like boom you're in heaven
nice rule is very simple dice roll one
works great it's like two shape layers
and like a few text layers and like
that's that's perfect
the water breathing one had easily the
most complicated coating it because the
thing with mogress is you have to code
everything like very efficiently using
the after effects Expressions yeah with
with Java and after effects
um and because you need because you also
in the one big downside of mogrits is
that you can't keyframe things in
Premiere when you bring them in so you
can't like oh let me have you know this
thing animate from you know do like a
slider that animates or something that
you have to all have it coded in and so
there's a lot of workarounds that you
have to do to get that and so instead of
just having like oh
um at frame zero I'm gonna have the
value at zero at frame uh tandema have
the value at 100. you have to code it so
it's like uh you have a slider that is
the time at which the animation starts
and a slider that is the time at which
it ends and then you have to drag those
sliders and then that uh those go into
like a linear expression they change the
verbiage as as this slider goes to this
slider makes the value go from this to
this every single time any single thing
that you want control of you have to
have a rig essentially like that it
doesn't feel like just doing it in After
Effects and like outputting it well I
mean you did or did it
this is
do you think it saved time in the long
run oh absolutely
there's so many like even just like the
initiative trackers like the order in
which everyone's going is completely
random every time so if I had to it
would be you know if everyone had the
same order every time it's like okay
cool we just export out drop top drop
you know the initiative tracker and
that's what the initiative is all the
time but like since everything changes
there's so many factors for every
moderate that's changing every time uh
you need to be able to just like drag
and drop and like duplicate and then
adjust some parameters here and then
duplicate and adjust some parameters
there like for the dice rolls it's like
this one was a dc15 and they rolled a 31
and this one's a dc2 or we don't want to
show the DC because it's not said and
then have it be result 18 you know and
then some of them are also like just a
quick roll the other one is like we're
building up the stakes for the most
important role ever and so if you had to
go back into after effects and then like
find those controls into it so it has to
be like okay I drop it in and there's a
slider that tells me how long I wanted
to roll for and how long it takes to
like reveal that it was that's good yeah
that makes sense how was that compared
to uh rendering all that stuff out of
unreal
like well yeah I mean very different you
did most of the unreal shots if not all
not all but most of all to in the uh big
mind flare battle where Ren dies in
episode seven yeah you did yeah like
there's a few episodes where and three
uh you did like the first half of the
stuff yeah they're like yeah fifty
percent of three yeah yeah for like
episode seven uh I'll let you do the big
explosions because I didn't know how to
do that it took a while to figure that
one out that was like a really
complicated well that's the thing that
we have like so many assets like we've
got like a thousand different particle
systems from the marketplace so it's
like which is the one that like looks
nice and then like how can we tweak it
to work so it took a while it is very
fun though because you're like watching
the edit and then you know these like I
do a matrix Dodge and like avoid this
lightning strike and I'm just like
okay
we figured out how to like unlock the
the rig so you could like animate the
rig and not just put it in like miximo
animations which which is awesome we
found out way too late in the season way
too late wait no I found a way I mean
because this is like the I don't know
the seventh or eighth unreal thing that
I've done with that involves like either
animation and mocap and I've been dying
to figure that out of like okay look you
have two characters but I need to tweak
the eye line and keep the rest of the
animation like what's the easiest way to
do it point a little bit more up and
then just like yeah and then yeah
awesome wait and for that point you
could not you didn't know how to
manipulate the maximum data at all like
I know
it's like a fast effective way of like
but like just like add to the y-axis
yeah you can figure out a way to like
open up the full like skeleton for the
model and like hand animate it and then
I was like huh so I took that and
applied it to a shot that had an
animation on it and it bakes the
animation out I'm like oh my God all the
keyframes are here it's not just like a
animation track yeah and now we can just
like make all the tweaks to the
animation it's like super easy yeah you
did that for the for chip with Chippy at
the end when he's talking to everybody
is just like breathing I have like I
needed to look around and like talk and
like you know acknowledge the other
characters that it's like speaking to as
a group like that kind of stuff
um
like though even like the crystal ball
shot at the end where it zooms in I'm
like oh sweet Idol animation Nico bake
it out head down look at the ball arm up
put the ball in the hand I'm like and
then it's still like being a bobbing and
it's just like yes hell yes finally yeah
finally that that sounds very helpful it
only took all of the episodes to figure
it out yeah it took two years basically
since I opened Unreal Engine yeah I
remember episode seven you're you're at
that point and I'm like he needs to bend
over for the lightning shot for the
Matrix please don't say this
it needs to happen as I'm leaving the
door to go to Ireland yeah you're
leaving for two weeks
um it's cool though yeah wow it's funny
because up until this point I just
realized like I've been so insular with
the visual effects side of things the
comp side of things I have not heard any
of that I didn't know about all this
stuff with unreal and yeah and the
mogritz issues and it's kind of crazy
because we work like right next to each
other for the most part yeah I hear
frustrations like occasionally
everyone's gonna just hear a big Huff
yeah but I've never it's funny to
contextualize it's like oh now some
conversations make sense that I like
over here in the yeah in the office yeah
yeah man wow it turned out though like
all your shots were super super dope and
like it was just cool to actually
finally have someone to like work and
collaborate with on an unreal project
finally yeah like like we've kind of
been doing that with like the local zero
stuff but it's more like kind of like
separate things that haven't even been
combined yet in different project files
but it's like
yeah I don't know it's I I don't know
I'm like an evangelist for unreal still
where it's like it's super cool renders
super fast like it's I don't know you
were living the life that Markiplier
wanted to live while he was yeah yeah
I want to learn everyone I'm like I'm
learning unreal
it's like Sam how do I do this
dance it's like the adult-sized baby
carrier on the front slots
pitching that Mark should have helped on
son of a dungeon I think I pitched that
to Daredevil so you should do like a he
should do a shot like one of the unreal
shots you did Pitch that yeah but it
didn't do it he was the French the
French method though that's like the
that was the technique here which was
like you know I was like hey guys I need
help in unreal here's some of the basics
and like here's maybe a tutorial or two
and then it you know two or three weeks
later it's like all right uh can you
start outputting Final Shots
it's like here's the file
can you please help make Final Shots
right now yeah the test didn't work that
well on me because it was too far out
Sam was like showing me the ropes of
unreal and I was like okay I'm getting
this I'm having a lot of fun doing the
shots and stuff and figuring out the
lighting but then it's like okay uh we
have uh three months until we have to
worry about this and I was like I gotta
worry about shooting tabletop right now
yeah yeah
this person needs to do this yeah that's
the thing is like there's so much on on
so few plates here it's like you kind of
have to pick and choose your battles
like uh there was a there's a really
cool
um node inside of nuke that opens up a
basically a dynamic link to unreal where
I could go in and I could pick the
camera and I could pick the scene and
unreal and I could instantly draw down
any passes that I needed any object ID
passes for mats any depth data but the
reality was like the time that we had to
do all these shots it was too short of a
time to build a reliable pipeline where
we could Implement that to where it just
came to a point where like well we'll
only worry about that kind of data on
shots where we absolutely need to for so
for this season it was the first time
that I also went into unreal and started
like you know Sam showed me around a
little bit and finding the cameras in
the scenes and then just pulling like
depth data via an exr output or
something like that to implement but
yeah there's like all these Cool Tools
and things that I'd love for us to
implement on future shows but I think
that's seven months to yeah yeah it
feels like the off season's the time to
start implementing those things which is
exciting but the big quality see like
the ceiling was still like but it's
still just like all right we're dealing
with like low poly well I mean they're
high poly but effect actively at that
distance they're like low poly photo
scans you know it's like yeah like the
lighting's way better this season figure
that out but ultimate and like yeah
things are a little sharper but like
when you really render like if you have
high quality Assets in unreal it's like
it looks just you can make it look as
good as blender you know and so it's
like how do you get that like extra late
because
like all the comps and stuff are awesome
and it's just like how do we
it feels green you watch it you're like
this looks sweet but it still feels like
a green screenshot because you're like
that background is like a toy and it's
like it could have more Fidelity yeah
low poly doll boy thing I mean to my uh
it kind of does lend itself nicely to
the vibe and aesthetic of it being a DND
game versus I guess full cinematic
immersion which is yeah it's nice
stylistically to my eye but I think for
evolution for season three I mean so
it's like I want to get that one one
level up yeah the next level up is just
bringing in as many friends as we can to
play as many cameos as all the NPCs I I
think yeah getting getting landlord
Steve in it for sure makeups costumes
yes that's gonna like go up on the
budget scale but it's gonna be worth it
for the weirdest cameos but but I think
if we can if we can Elevate the renders
yeah that would be super cool we just
need a super high resolution laser
scanner oh yeah like sick I don't know
that that's because having to do with
photogrammetry I think might be the the
setback if it was like actual like laser
scanning if we get some really dense
like high quality models is so we didn't
do laser scanning for what we did this
time we did photos just all photos yeah
and I wonder you know is there a room
like obviously the the light psych idea
or there's another name for it I've
always called it light psych it's the
Mandalorian uh LED wall
um that implementing that if if we were
on a stage with that what would that
that look like because I'm thinking you
know you obviously you shoot the game
footage then maybe
assemble the edit first before any of
the green screens green screen stuff is
shot we would just kind of do things
backwards yeah exactly sense that like
yeah like all of the CG renders would be
rendered and outputted and put in the
edit first yeah yeah because that feels
like the next and then the very final
like literally the last stages we filmed
this stuff on a volume and we're
dropping into the edit and we're hitting
export like it requires that level
process because you know like going
through the show it's like he's we
filmed the green screen stuff but that
was like basically 10 backgrounds like
yeah in this part of the map but we
haven't rendered anything that's like
final here yet so like all the
lighting's changing objects like oh
continuity uh they're supposed to be
people back there or like there's a
spell effect happening it's like you
only know that when you get through the
whole show and have rendered out all the
shots and like understand it all even
like you're just watch when we were
q-seating episode nine last year looking
at the Astro playing stuff and you're
like oh there's like some weird titling
let me just read yeah all of those shots
yeah every single literally two days
before we hit like the final ex no two
days why am I talking about the same day
the final episode nine stuff I was like
I don't like this astral playing stuff I
see tiling unlike some objects back
there so I just re-render all the shots
and it takes like a half hour I'm so
insanely jealous of that and watching
you render out of unreal still just
frustrates me man it's so fast can you
uh fix these shots yeah literally go to
the bathroom come back stands like all
right they're rendering out yeah I
rendered out all the underwater stuff
and Carmichael's like you need some like
fish in there or something like hmm so I
spent like a half hour putting fish in
and I rear and render all the shots I'm
like they're done premiere's like still
opening yeah
I rendered a shot from Sam's computer
and I walked to my desk to refreshed the
note and it just loaded into new the new
plate that's the ultimately why it's so
fun though because you're just like
here's the final product you hit render
it's basically done
there's no waiting yeah in the green
screen when I made the opening logos you
know the quarter digital aperture like
all that's like Dude in After Effects
like I just hit render on these logos
and it's like 15 minutes remaining like
what like this is like a PNG that I
already rendered out of octane dude's
waiting 24 hours I don't know how lucky
you are I just put some like Bloom on
this dude and it's like 15 minutes
surrender each one like what is going on
yeah
The Classy final title where it's just
literally text in Premiere dude the
Georgia font I know it's like the Elven
ring Japanese game Vibe you know if like
you know when they use that default font
like like any of those like from
software games where it's just like like
it's that Vibe where you're like dude
this is serious now like
no more shows we don't have time we just
gotta get the information that's like
sponsors out of the way this is so cool
we don't even need a neat cool font
oh my gosh this this show
yeah
um
have you guys played DND I have yet to
ever play a game you've never played
Austin has played and dm'd yeah yeah I
usually DM I did a DM I did a DM I did I
did after I did a meme
it was a wild night I did a fun like
Halloween one shout out to my friends
that was just like stranger things oh
that's six kids on bikes it's very fun
yeah you also made a uh like summer camp
game too yeah I had I had a camp game
it's like that you play as summer camp
counselors and your kids have gone gone
missing and then you have to go through
like a dungeon to get them back each
each room is based on like the kids
fears okay so it's like six one kid's
afraid of bugs and so there's like a
mechanic that uh like creates like giant
monster bugs you have to you know stop
that oh it's awesome I I would love to
save all the kids yeah I would love to
get any kind of rep in on that because
it just like I grew up as a you know I
acted as a child and I spent like a lot
of years in like improv classes
[Laughter]
and for me it just it feels like that's
the purest form of just improv meets
game meets hangout it just it looks like
so much fun it was never on my radar
growing up I never had friends who who
did it or
it's like yeah it's more complicated
than like you know we did that improv
session the other week but like even in
that improv session there's like some
rules which is like stand next to
another person turn to them and create a
personality and then the other person
mirrors it it's like yeah it's improv
but those are still rules and DND like
yeah maybe there's more rules but you
know it's only because it's designed to
handle way more types of situations so
but there's also this it's the same core
there's also the belief that
constriction you know actually produces
greater creativity yes as opposed to
just unlimitless sandbox which I think
is true also of Dungeons and Dragons
because you have to do it inside of this
this box to some degree which I I just I
like the sound of it man you guys play
it as just when you have like a very
specific character too you have a very
like you know a very specific way that
you have to play you know like D's like
I always got to be dark and edgy yeah
yesterday decision
and so it's fun to
have an improv session but you're not
improving as yourself you're improving
is a very very specific individual
that's kind of like dming too is you get
to do that but with like a million
different individuals because you're all
the NPCs so it's like okay this is the
very serious bartender and then you're
like oh and then this is like the goofy
uh the goofy guy that comes in for comic
relief everyone can beat up on or
something you know or Rob yeah I'm sure
they would find a way to Rob him
things yes yeah and the big thing which
I think like all you guys are good at
especially when I see you guys on
Corridor crew it
it's not just improving like what's the
funniest thing I can say right now but
it's also it's improving the story is
like how do I move this forward how do I
move this along you gave me something
how do I take this and like build on it
in the stories direction that I believe
we're all trying to get to yeah
I know it's LARPing at a table who
here's gun LARPing I have not gone
I was moments away from going to this
one huge LARP event in like Montreal why
didn't you it's you remember Adam Lyons
yes yeah so he was like hardcore into
LARPing and he's like he's like the
Robin Hood at like the Texas Renaissance
Fair like he's like the main you know he
he's so into it that he's
you know he's yeah he's on billboards oh
my gosh weather Fair yeah um but he was
telling me he went to this uh beakling I
think it's called it's maybe I'm
butchering its pronunciation in a castle
but it's called beakling or something
like that and it's basically it's a
multi-day LARP event where you like have
factions and you're sleeping in tents
and you can like when you buy your
ticket it's like it's like burning man
where you can like do you want to stay
in a tent you want to stay in a lodge
with food are you gonna bring your own
tent like like there what's where are
you on the tier I mean the king yeah
it's like the King goes technically the
game doesn't end during while you're
sleeping because yeah there's like night
raids
and foam swords once it begins it begins
it begins and like there's like multiple
factions there's like a there's a
faction of just Orcs And monsters and
fairies and stuff like this and there's
like combat and like trade across like
five days question it's so actually
crazy question yeah in LARPing yeah it's
like the sword and shield stuff yeah I
mean you just hit someone with a foam
sword
yeah there's a massive honor thing okay
because it's not like they have painted
they don't have like paint on it and if
you've got paint on you you lost that
limb because all it takes is One Bad
Apple to get called out and everyone's
like you're out of the game dude get the
hell out of here but do you have to like
leave leave or is there a graveyard
it's just a waiting room and you gotta
wait for the next three days you're like
dang I died on day one like hope the
medic finds me yeah yeah
it's pretty crazy my ghost that kind of
just roams around oh that'd be fun you
can like just tell on the other side
he's like cross Enemy Lines and tell
Tales yeah
been doing it since 94.
it's yeah it's like multiple Acres with
two method Villages there's a I forget
the name of it there's a LARP event
that's 4 000 people go into it that's
small compared to the one that I found
the one I found is at about 10 to 12
000. Jesus those are real warring tribes
it's a real the event like a drone shot
there's a video of it uh on YouTube
where they broke it down it's the size
of the town next to the area yeah no but
like it's like multi-war tournament
battle like events this event has like
there's like a trade and like an economy
system too where like you get assets and
resources so you like you get like sheep
they have like cards for it and stuff
and so when you're like going to these
other parties like you can you can raid
their like resources and stuff don't
take my shoes there's like action
there's like actual campaigns and quests
as part of it too that like your faction
can get which is like all right we have
to go and take these people out or we
have to go and like convince them to
give us a bunch of stuff so we can bring
it to the King
as a sheep one of the sheep yeah I'm
just like stolen
[Laughter]
movies that do like Quest giving NPCs
they're essentially walking around there
we've got bugs in my home they're
standing there in the woods just waiting
dude
[Laughter]
I'm going to a LARP event what are you
what are you going to be a warrior no
I'm an NPC
yeah yeah but like it can take multiple
hits and stuff there's like a whole
system with your character and wow it's
so much more involved than I expected
it's really cool it's had so many years
to evolve man I'm just but for real
though like if you died in the in the
first battle of the first day and you
paid to go there for three days you're
telling me that someone doesn't go it's
probably a thing where they like you
know you probably are you you
know you're incapacitated or something
you you get brought back to like this
Village and then the next day you're
better you know you gotta walk back to
town go to the start Point wait your
turn it's same thing in pain load your
save yeah I mean they do it with airsoft
games too exactly a huge multi-day meal
Sim games and stuff and I've just seen
so many videos of people like faking in
an air software they just don't they act
like they didn't get hit yeah that was
because I think it's just because it's
hard because Airsoft you're so far away
when people get hit you know airsoft
snipers like they're like someone's like
and then someone's like huh was that a
bugger I don't know yeah
than a very aggressive bug now
uh I would be down to do that shoot we
should do something that'd be really fun
yeah the big yeah the big one everyone
goes to Quebec and yeah let's just
record our Quebec trip oh my God
that would be like Daniel will have a
blast yeah so many cameras yeah that's
so true oh yeah and I was thinking like
when we were doing all those node LARP
videos I was like dude let's just like
black out our GoPros and put them on
chest mounts and and put hide them in
our armor and then like film the full
things covertly wait can we do that at
the retreat the uh Quebec can you
imagine if we did a retreat and we had
two warring factions I mean that would
make for some it's like you have to take
it super seriously like everyone who has
to like it's full costume first off
yeah
be prepared to be outside for at least
eight hours minimum like that and then
then you got something I think oh man
it's so rigorous that I can't like
unless I prepare my vegan meals I don't
know if I could do it
no
no you do a Camelback full of peanut
butter oh I'm just chugging it
oh man good neck muscles will get really
strong yeah
[Laughter]
breaking fact of life that I was never
prepared for is when you get like a
milkshake and it's too thick to drink
they give you a spoon and it's like the
rudest thing ever it's like don't you're
weak you can't it's not ice cream yeah
it's like you you were failing yeah you
failed to make the milk
since you expect and you're failing that
at least give me a bigger a wider straw
yeah give me a thick straw like a boba
straw yeah there you go
man wow you guys have opened up a whole
new world to me LARPing and dungeon
dragons yeah it would be nice to get a
weapon like if we did something in the
studio or something like that like yeah
some off-camera game yeah that would I
would really love that that would be a
lot those are way easier yeah
let's do like a one shot you know like
it's so easy although if yeah depending
on WE it's still top secret but if if we
do uh
there's another there's a secret game
that we were talking about doing and if
you want to be a part of it uh you can
be a part of it yup yes it's an open
invitation almost anyone who wants to do
it can be it because it's flexible
enough where we can have I don't know as
many people as there are in the studio
technically being in it I was kind of
wondering if anything like anyone
I would say 15 people like Max okay like
total like you know what I'm saying like
oh my gosh it's a game that's big enough
that we can handle probably about 15
people when hypothetically I won't hold
you to it are we thinking I'm not gonna
tell you no hypothetically secret top
secret oh we'll say is get some good get
a good night's sleep tonight
I wake up covered in Wool it's like it's
begun
and there's like there's one D20 and one
D6 you're like but that's not all the
dice the guys had at the table because
your sheep dice oh man get rolling it's
the first real-time endurance DND game
where time never fast forwards or so is
that yeah rests are the actual amount of
time in game that it takes to rest
if you don't get back to the table when
your rest is over uh that's the world
continues on yeah you never wake up and
you're just lying there helpless in the
dungeon that is cool like like a
real-time Dungeons and Dragons game
a d d game where we have to LARP for the
combat where we step away from the table
and just actually have to fight you just
shoot people
like it's just like oh my God two grown
men in wrestling yeah you need a crowd
of people eager to fight oh my God
yeah Firebox is a good idea Bard boxing
well so this is not a secret project
idea so Jake every time he has those
one-on-one fights he you know [ __ ] up
royally because he's a Bard and doesn't
fight well so like we've you know and
there's like three of them in the season
where he's just he's like here's like a
low-level guy who's level one I'm gonna
kill him and then he spends like 10
minutes yes dude yes like why don't we
pick two of those characters against
each other and it's a charity barred
boxing match so these two unequipped
people have to like duke it out oh I
love that which just creates the these
hilarious like way too like overly
prolonged like fight sequences where
none of them are actually dealing damage
is very like theatrical you know it's
like wrestling yeah
and deal damage
that's so funny yeah that one is just
that one keeps coming back it's too good
to pass up yeah so instead of season
three Bard boxing good example wow
that's gold you would be in the universe
too it would be like all right this
happens
he's organizing it yeah and he might
even he might even compete
he's in the finale exactly yeah he's the
final matchup yeah
wow he has PTSD so he can't go through
all the rounds he just has to be at the
final round
well whenever you decide to you know the
secret take the top secret off that that
sweet idea you got oh it's highly secret
oh I'm fine it's so secret I I texted
Sam because I wanted to tell Alicia
about it and then I was like wait
she might be in it Sam can I tell Alicia
first thing he says you can't kill
anyone no it's a campaign so so
ambitious that if we tell a single
person about it it could potentially
ruin the entire experience I just I
worry because the only time that I've
ever done anything in this realm with
you Sam was actually on the podcast the
single player one the single player one
let's end up naked and dead very quick
naked immediately solo by choice
by not Choice easy to die okay so I feel
a little better is it easy to get nude
because yeah
that's how much armor you have on
because it takes longer to take off I
mean you could be nude with armor yeah
just keep the cheeks open yeah I know no
I did a prison break game and that was
like the first thing
instantly and so they're desperately
trying to break out of this like like uh
it's like the it's like this uh the yard
so to speak the prison yard and they're
like doing everything they're trying to
escape because you know blah blah the
story and so they're like one of them's
just like you know I'm trying my best to
intimidate this guy I'm just gonna go
nude and like and go Barbarian and just
shock him with my nudity that's genius
and it actually you know rolls worked in
his favor but like it's also like so
then they proceed to escape with one of
them naked in this like sewer oh my gosh
that is hilariously good too because you
can have a thing where it's like oh I
killed the guard like all right I'm
gonna take his clothes and you're just
like it's a halfling it's too small
clothes are too small they don't fit
these pants or your underwear yeah well
because I've seen I've seen videos on
these nudity and DND as oh boy I got
another one that's a really good one oh
hit me with it so
this is years back now but it was like a
one shot where it's like all right
everyone's trying to lose your virginity
you're in high school this is it's after
the medieval prom and we're all going
you guys are coming the medieval ball
prom thing so we're at this you're at
you got the keys to this big house and
you know no one's gonna be there and you
know there's gonna be some girls and so
they go in there and you know I have
like basically the random assortment of
these female characters that pair with
the male ones all different races and
stuff like that and everyone like you
know starts trying to get their hookups
and like lose their virginity and then
Nico it was like for some reason decided
so like I was like I'm gonna be a gnome
you know the the you know the runt of
the group and then like the girl he ends
up with is like the like the I forget it
was like a half orc or something like
that huge huge yeah and then like and
then through happenstance they end up at
the room that I have like the only trap
door like one like the bed the bed in
the room is right over the trap door and
so the vigorous movement of the bed like
sets off the trap door that I have there
which Ben ends up having unique they're
all level one so he he basically is on
the bed it shakes sets off the trap door
and he falls through the trap door and
the fall from like that's where he is
down to like the sewer underneath the
haunted house was enough damage to
incapacity
it sounds like it's a good number for
rocking in the bed the door sprays open
screws up the deck save the half more
cops out of the bed before
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
where you as the DM describing
describing the ax that we're going
yeah well I mean it's it's like it's
like a bridge it's kind of like you know
if you imagine the country you begin you
imagine the cut scene it's like the like
the bars come in the two of them walk
into a room door's closed you're just
starting
and it's like you proceed to lose your
virginity yeah however just because of
the circumstances like like we had that
additional yeah like a Dragon Age Origin
cut scene yeah yeah I thought you had
prepared like everyone's own Top Gun sex
sequence ready to go grabbing the shot
no no I I I I you know it's like that's
not what they're there traffic
depictions of the medieval sex yeah
describe me having sex foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that same exact scenario happened to me
in high school yeah
a
[Laughter]
[ __ ] ring of the revivalify all right
all right
yeah that's a great note to wrap this up
yeah
now let us know what you guys think and
uh yeah if they want sex scenes for
season two
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's fun to watch and I'm
everyone loves it everyone loves it
reception yeah I think that's I think
episode nine is a great reward to all
the feelings that happen in episode
seven feelings
yeah that's what I noticed in the
comments it's all about those feelings
yeah
all right well can't beat that all right
guys next time